this tiny heart is about to beat for the
very first time
In This Moment a cluster of developing
cells begins a rhythmic pulse that will
last a lifetime
but why now what triggers the heart to
start beating at this precise moment and
how do all the cells start to contract
in synchrony
for each heart there's only one chance
to catch that very first beat so
scientists have been using microscopes
fluorescent proteins arrays of zebrafish
embryos and a lot of patience to explore
this pivotal moment
[Music]
thank you
these are zebrafish embryos each less
than one millimeter long
their hearts start beating only 20 hours
after fertilization well before the
growing organism actually needs its
heart functions
to visualize the heartbeats the
researchers used fluorescent proteins
which glow in response to their
surroundings
here the pink fluorescent proteins
represent a voltage Spike which causes a
spike of calcium ions seen here in green
and it's this calcium Spike which causes
the cells to contract
in the adult fish the beating of the
heart is controlled by a pacemaker
region a group of cells which control
the speed of contractions in the rest of
the organ
for the first heartbeats the researchers
found no clear pacemakers different
embryos had different cells that started
beating first and they triggered the
cells around them in a wave-like pattern
in this experiment the cells in the
bottom left of this image start the
pulse which travels across the heart
but when researchers silenced those
cells this region of cells takes over as
the starting point of each pulse
so what starts the process what kicks
off the chain reaction the answer is
perhaps nothing in particular
it seems that as the cells mature in the
developing embryo they grow gradually
more and more sensitive to electrical
signals after a while they become so
sensitive to Natural electrical noise in
the tissue around them that some of the
cells start activating at random
this activates the cells next to them
and the ones next to those and so on
until a pulse spreads across the heart
for the first time
gradually eventually a steady rhythm is
established
the team think that this is how those
very first heartbeats originate in quite
a haphazard way very different to the
tightly controlled Rhythm of the adult
heart
understanding this key point in
development could help researchers study
what goes wrong in embryos with
congenital heart conditions or it could
be useful for engineering stem cells
that can be implanted into a damaged
heart and which need to sync up with the
rhythm of the patient's own heart issues
the heart Works continuously during its
lifetime through adrenaline rushes and
exhaustion until our final moments but
it couldn't happen without that very
first heartbeat
foreign